con estas expulsiones está rusia como
dice la canciller angela merkel alejada
del estado de derecho
mire yo creo que lo que ha pasado son
las últimas horas revelan que esta
crisis en rusia hay que necesariamente
buscarla desde dos perspectivas
una situación relativa con el barco
interno en función de la crisis que pasa
rusia en el segmento socioeconómico
agravado por la pandemia la crisis rusia
viene desde antes de la pandemia y para
mí la oposición encuentra que es
tristeza esa debilidad puede accionar y
el otro escenario por el que
necesariamente tenemos que analizar
estas crisis crisis es el marco externo
puesto que si usted revisa la noticia de
los últimos dos meses encontrar con una
fuerte ofensiva externa que sobre rusia
en relación con la efectividad de la
vacuna por ejemplo ahora con exploración
por naval y la condena que tiene que
cumplir en cárcel de manera que hay una
ofensiva
desde afuera contra rusia de mí desde mi
punto de vista y en esta ofensiva es la
esto que ha pasado a tener una posición
más agresiva es europa y lo más
llamativo que desde dentro de dentro de
la reunión europea sea alemania que es
el actor con el que lució tiene un mayor
vínculo particularmente el sector
energético
bueno y es que como ha sido
históricamente en occidente las noticias
que no favorecen a rusia pues son una
constante y ahí yo le quisiera preguntar
cómo ha estado marcada esta relación en
los últimos años
pero necesariamente hay que realizar la
nueva en función del corto plazo punto
que muchos colocan el acento de la
crisis entre rusia y occidente a partir
de los lados del asunto de grange tímea
el 2014 es verdad que la relación se
empeoró presidente rusia a partir de la
anexión o reincorporación de crimea a
rusia pero la crisis final es desde
bastante antes desde mi punto de vista
desde el mismo fin de la guerra fría
cuando occidente consideró que había que
mantener a rusia debilitada y tras ese
objetivo puso en marcha estrategias
tendientes a la expansión de la otan ha
sido la principal y creo que es el punto
que más irrita a rusia una potencia de
restricción política de manera que eso
está relacionado con la situación actual
de presión